thank you guys i'm here with alares
surely a little bit of the analysis was
spoiled but i was hoping that you could
take us through some deeper lines i was
particularly interested what was your
thought process and your psychological
reaction when he plays queen g3 it must
have been a move that shocked you
yeah queen g3 is insane
i mean
he played it also very quickly i think
five minutes maybe he thought about it
and it is just insane so
um
i immediately understood that if i take
this was my plan originally but i
understood that he wants to take
and just play h4 so or f4 h4
and i was just scared
[Laughter]
so it's because somebody giving this
piece like this then
and he there is no immediate mate
then
it means i don't understand this
position so
um i didn't go for this so
let me pull you back you didn't
understand the position and you still
felt that it you were too scared to go
into a piece up yeah i just
i just trusted him so
um i just wanted to make more
play a bit more
so
you know this is amazing idea yeah we've
seen through the rapid and blitz that
when strong players gave you pieces or
pawns you just took them
what caused you to trust your opponent
today
yeah he's in a very good shape
so
what can i say i mean he's playing very
good skill
but i played knight c5 i think i'm a bit
worse okay at least i'm playing at least
here so
um i was happy that he doesn't have
bishop h6 at least yeah
how do you feel about the position yeah
i think the f4 is a great move also yeah
takes takes and he exactly exchanges
amazing and
queen f6 yeah he just played quickly
bishop d3 i didn't understand why i mean
bishop is really looked very
very reasonable like very logical i
think everybody will play bishop v3 yeah
did you get to listen to his explanation
on what he missed yeah listen um yeah
this idea he had it was weird but
yeah obviously he plundered quincy once
yeah what you got seen in advance right
yeah
um so yeah after bishop bistro
everything's just equal maybe i was
bitter at some point
they just did give you a little bit of
an edge all the way down when i think
you took an a4 here
because after bishop before rookie 6
here here bishop c7 they did not like so
much 26 but maybe check and rookie one
and start attacking yes
yeah it was within the shock of queen g3
i wanted to make draw and go home
and goal achieved how do you feel you
played in this game i think i played
well but okay still i was i think much
worse so
i felt that i played very solidly at
least so i i'm happy with my play until
now alright you seem to be in great
shape another game maybe not exactly
perfect for you but you defended very
well you still think that you're in
great shape yeah i think i'm in a good
shape um
yesterday i played a good game but
nepo also when i lost he played a very
good game so
i cannot be very sad about that so i'm
i'm happy how this thing's going and
there are many more rounds to go so
absolutely well thank you larissa for
joining us here in the show we still
have one queen end game guys so don't go
anywhere we'll be here another five or
six hours but thank you for joining us
in the show ali reza i have a question
for you please uh if you don't mind and
you mentioned also the queen c1 i'd just
like to ask you your opinion if
he had tested you in this position with
bishop e5 and rook g4 this whole line
because peter and i we just went down
this rabbit hole and we want to share
our analysis
just wonder what your opinion was on
this outcome like 24 specifically like
this position queen e4 5 queen d4 did
you did you consider it and if you did
what did you think this was like no i
didn't i didn't see anything i mean
during the game i didn't even see the
idea of rook g44
so
really yeah it's it's very tough to see
i mean it's not very logical no i mean
rook g4 takes f4 it's not a common
common stuff so when did when did you
notice it no i never noticed anything he
told me after the game
an honest man okay this is this answers
our question i guess yeah yes
thank you ali raza and very good luck to
you and your remaining games
be very hard to put the band to the test
but i didn't even see a four very very
nice